hallo leute und herzlich willkommen
zurück bei super easy german dieses
video ist eine ergänzung zu unserem
video von der letzten woche dort ging es
um die steigerung von adjektiven
vielleicht habt ihr schon mal gehört
dass es im deutschen zwei verschiedene
arten von adjektiven gibt es gibt
prädikat iwe adjektive die immer in
verbindung mit einem verb stehen zum
beispiel der film ist spannend und es
gibt attribut iwe adjektive die stehen
immer direkt vor einem normen und werden
mit dem nomen fleck tiert zum beispiel
das ist ein spannender film letzte woche
haben wir die steigerungsform für
prädikat iwe adjektive geübt und haben
euch immer hier verschiedene
steigerungen gezeigt in dieser woche
möchten wir euch auch zeigen wie das
ganze für attribut iwe adjektive geht
wenn man sich die steigerungsform von
prädiktiven adjektiven und attribut even
adjektiven anguckt dann sieht man dass
sie sehr ähnlich sind
hier sind zwei beispiele zum beispiel
das buch ist spannend
dieses buch ist spannender dieses buch
ist am spannendsten
das sind die prädikat even adjektive das
was wir letzte woche gemacht haben jetzt
attribut eve das ist ein spannendes buch
das ist ein spannendes buch und das ist
das spannendste buch hier seht ihr es
gibt einen kleinen unterschied ist nicht
sehr groß aber wenn man die beiden
verwechselt dann kann man manchmal
fehler machen
zum beispiel haben wir unter unserem
letzten video diesen kommentar gelesen
das war am besten video das ist ein
klassischer fehler den viele von euch
machen wenn man das ganze als attribut
iwes adjektiv also vor dem nomen nimmt
dann muss man das natürlich anders
steigern
also ihr müsst sagen das war das beste
video
und diese attribut even adjektive und
die steigerungen davon
die üben wir jetzt mit euch los geht's
das ist ein altes fahrrad
das ist ein noch älteres fahrrad mit dem
ältesten sattel den ich gesehen habe
das ist das dicke buch das ist ein
dickeres buch das ist das dickste buch
das ist ein billiges restaurant das ist
ein billigeres restaurant
das ist das billigste restaurant ja sagt
das ist ein leckerer t aber er sagt auch
das ist ein lecker relativ und das ist
der leckerste tv janisch ja mich denkst
du die auch alle reagieren ja das ist
eine hässliche ecke das ist eine
hässliche ecke ja mich sagt sie ist ganz
hübsch eigentlich das ist die
hässlichste ecke das sind warme
handschuhe
das sind wärmere handschuhe und das sind
im wärmsten handschuhe
das ist ein schnelles auto
das ist ein schnelleres auto das ist das
schnellste auto
janisch zeigt uns seine gitarren
das ist eine gute gitarre
das ist eine bessere gitarre und das ist
die beste gitarre von janosch das ist
ein neues geschäft
das ist ein neueres geschäft
das ist das neueste geschäft auf der
straße das ist ein hässliches plakat das
ist ein hässliches plakat das ist das
hässlichste plakat das war unser video
für heute wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen wie ihr gesehen habt werden die
meisten adjektive nach dem gleichen
muster gesteigert aber es gibt auch
manchmal unregelmäßige adjektive mit
unregelmäßigen steigerungen wie zum
beispiel gut besser am besten um diese
adjektive zu lernen könnt ihr einfach
mal nach unregelmäßigen adjektiven
googeln und dann werdet ihr eine liste
bekommen die liste ist nicht so lang
also guckt sie euch einfach mal an und
lernt einfach die wichtigsten adjektive
auswendig und deren komparative und
superlative auch wenn ihr nach übungen
machen wollt dann könnt ihr wie immer
ein patch 1 bei uns werden und dort
findet ihr interaktive übungen bei denen
ihr dieses ganze thema noch mal zu hause
an eurem computer üben können das geht
hierbei patchen und bitte gibt uns einen
daumen nach oben wenn euch das video
gefallen hat darüber würden wir uns sehr
freuen
ihr könnt ihr easyjet übrigens
abonnieren bis nächste woche dann sind
wir zurück mit einem neuen thema es wird
eine überraschung für euch sein